y le preguntó primero los talibanes
anunciaron en ese momento que
implementarían un nuevo sistema que
concordara con la ley islámica Qué dice
Exactamente esa ley al respecto Y qué
pasó con esta promesa
Hola buenas tardes Muchas gracias por
tenernos en cuenta mi día internacional
Bueno en realidad
la idea que tienen los talibanes de
aplicar las áreas no las áreas no dice
nada sobre la educación o si dice algo
No desde luego no niega la educación a
las niñas en ningún caso no este año de
talibán se ha convertido en un año de
promesas incumplidas y se ha perseguido
directamente a las mujeres en todos los
aspectos no solo en la educación No
porque se les ha obligado a llevar el
velo integral preferiblemente el burka
evitar movimientos innecesarios siendo
teniendo que ser acompañadas de un
acompañante masculino tienen restringido
su derecho a la libertad de movimiento
la libertad de expresión y asociación
etcétera y además efectivamente aunque
prohibía aunque en un principio dijeron
que iban a abrir los escuelas para todo
el mundo el 23 de marzo se presentaron
las niñas de secundaria en las escuelas
y les prohibieron directamente
les dijeron que se tenía
que no podían quedarse en las escuelas
con lo cual frustraron su necesidad y su
derecho a la educación
señor Zaragoza y que pueden hacer los
organismos internacionales para defender
estos derechos de las mujeres afganas
que han venido siendo violados en el
último año
bueno nosotros desde internacional lo
que hacemos Es pedir en general a los
gobiernos que hagan una incidencia
política internacional también actuamos
ante la ONU y lo que pedimos básicamente
es que se adopten medidas urgentes para
garantizar la participación plena y
significativa de las mujeres en todos
los ámbitos incluido el de la educación
que se permita el acceso completo a la
educación de las mujeres y niñas que se
garantice el respeto y la protección de
los derechos de las mujeres y las niñas
frente a violencias cometidas por estos
talibanes y que no queden impunes estas
violaciones no garantizar que todos los
actos de violencia de género contra las
mujeres en general y otras violaciones y
abusos contra los Derechos Humanos de
las mujeres y las niñas se investiguen
sobre todo no que no que no hay que
acabar con la impunidad y hay que
cooperar totalmente con el relator
especial de las Naciones Unidas que se
creó en su momento para sobre la
situación
volver a lo que ocurrió ocurría justo
antes de estar los talibanes en el poder
que aunque no era perfecto era muchísimo
mejor sin duda alguna
brevemente usted habla de lo que había
antes de que llegaran los talibanes al
poder cuáles eran esos derechos que
habían ganado a lo largo de los años y
que ahora se están violando brevemente
por favor
bueno
había fundamentalmente una constitución
que se aplicaba bastante bien había un
Ministerio de asuntos para la mujer
había unas unidades de violencia contra
la mujer que ayudaban a las mujeres que
sufrían violencia doméstica había un
sistema bastante bastante democrático en
el que los derechos humanos se
respetaban muchísimo más que ahora no
con la llegada de los talibanes se ha
vuelto atrás hace pues a los años 90 en
el que pues han vuelto las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales los homicidios
ilegítimos hay una
torturas etcétera no Entonces se ha
cambiado mucho se ha empeorado muchísimo
la